this is as far as rescue workers have
been able to go they found no signs of
life only dust and ash a desolate layer
that veils white island authorities have
given up hope of finding any survivors
the families of the missing have not
gavin tallow and his partner lisa
Hosking were among those on the volcano
on a tour with their teenage daughter
Zoey Hosking we do know they were on the
island if not but I said this morning it
was on the ABC news that had notified
the ones that were missing and they
didn't come up there so at the moment we
think they'd might be in the hospital
the family later said that Lisa Hosking
had been found in a hospital in New
Zealand
the terror of the eruption in the fear
and confusion several Birds managed to
escape white island or curry evacuating
tourists eight people were left trapped
and they are presumed dead families are
hoping either for a miracle or that
their relatives were among those
spirited away and now receiving
treatment in New Zealand there are 47
people on the island when it erupted
Hayden Marshall Inman was a local tour
guide he was leading the group and he's
been confirmed dead
Tiffany money is also a tour guide his
family does not know where he is but
shocked we were shocked because up until
then we didn't know what was really
happening on the island and we're still
hopeful that he's still alive here
somewhere many the tourists were
passengers on this cruise ship ovation
of the Seas it had been waiting in Port
but today it slipped anchor white island
is still smoldering too dangerous to
search properly experts have estimated
the chance of another eruption at 1550
the recovery operation must wait and so
too must families who fear the worst
Tom Cheshire Sky News